it's been several years now that the
plastic problem is not in the middle of
the discussion I mean it's kind of a
forgotten side which is not not a good
thing definitely um but uh if we're
talking about the public H the people
the
consumers um the people who make a
change in the world which is this is the
the consumers that's what eventually
they do the the evolution um the the
revolution um
I can say that I I can say two things
first of all and consumers totally
understand what composable packaging in
is and are looking for composable
packages all surveys not by Tia but by
other companies show that there is a
huge demand for compostible packaging
consumers are seeking for comp for for
companies who do not use conventional
plastic and definitely comforable
packaging is the solution for that
[Music]
DNA niss B welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me today
how are you good good H and thank you
for having me today thank you so much
for joining me I'm I'm really excited to
speak with you about a world that I care
a lot about I don't know nearly enough
about and that's exactly why I'm doing
this show so I'm I'm excited to be
inspired by a whole new and important
world out there uh talking about your
journey as a as an entrepreneur founding
tipa a multinational company in the
sustainability space clean tech with um
a composable um packaging um really
excited to even unpack what that means
no pun intended to unpack it um just
thought of that now um you know
packaging is all around us obviously so
even before we get to talk about you
know your journey as an entrepreneur to
founding Tia tell me a little bit about
what's happening in the world of
packaging
manufacturing what what's happening here
okay so first of all you're right it's
it's a huge industry uh we're talking
about U more than $100 billion dollar
annually that goes into packaging yeah
it's it's a huge
industry um in the industry is divided
between food and non food I mean there
are a few
sectors that use packaging but food is
definitely the majority of the usage so
around two3 of all packaging goes into
the food industry it's a huge industry
that uses a lot of uh a lot of packaging
and if we focus on the food industry so
in general the food industry is divided
to two there are more rigid packages
like like bottles okay like bottles like
jars stuff like that and then there's
flexible packaging so flexible packaging
are all those soft packages just imagine
granola BR wrap or or a potato chips bag
etc etc fresh produce bread so all those
are flexible packaging so this is the
market it's a huge Market it's a market
that um actually it's diverse globally
so everywhere we go there's a food
manufacturing I mean there's packaging
manufacturing
infrastructure
um and it's
definitely um a a subject or a challenge
that we have to face in order to live in
a better world in a few years time what
impact does packaging have on the future
or world how big of it how big of an
impact does it have huge because
um currently the majority of the
packages are made from conventional
plastic and there are studies who show
that con conventional plastic package
can last for hundreds of years so it
doesn't really matter to me if it's 400
or 600 or a thousand of years but those
are the numbers that are mentioned um so
today we can say that every piece of
plastic that was ever manufactured is
still someplace around us unless it was
incinerated which is not a solution
anyway but plastic is here to stay so
it's it's it's an easy material to use
it's cheap etc etc but it lasts forever
and because it lasts forever that's the
reason that we see so much plastic
everywhere you know in the ocean
ions in open yards in in the water that
we drink microplastic is everywhere
microplastic is everywhere it's in our
food it's in our water it's in the air
um and as as long as we continue to use
plastic like there's no tomorrow L
literally um we'll have this problem
just raising and
growing um and there are
alternatives okay so now going back a
little bit to your own Journey you know
tell me a little bit about your
upbringing how how has your life LED you
to be passionate and excited about
helping tackle the um this issue of
plastic or packaging to something more
sustainable um so my background is not
plastic it's not even materials
engineering it's um it's actually
software and so I'm by education I'm a
software engineer started in in serving
in the Israeli Navy and then did a few
career changes throughout my life uh but
around 12 years ago I had kind of a
discussion with my children around what
happens to the plastic bottles that they
take to
school and I went out jogging and I
thought to myself there must be a a
different way to to use packaging or an
alternative to plastic packaging I knew
about the problem that plastic is a is a
material that lasts forever
and the first thing that came to my mind
and I thought to myself what what would
be the
solution the most intuitive solution for
us to use packaging and the first thing
that came to my mind was an apple
because when we eat an apple and we
throw the residuals into the waist bin
it just disintegrates and bades by
itself right so just imagine an orange
pill so if you put the orange pill in a
bean the best the best way to put it to
discard it is into a compost bin but
let's say if even if it goes to a
regular bin it breaks down to small
parts and then turns into soil into
compost and the idea was to emulate
nature to create to to invent a package
that actually does the same so we use
the package as a package and it needs to
be as good as conventional plastic but
once we finished using it and we discard
it into the organic waste beIN in turn
it turns into a soil with a within a
very short period of time which is up to
months so just imagine that all the
packages that we use today that last
forever can turn into a new resource a
very important resource which is compost
compost is a
fertilizer and that's actually the
circular economy approach so nature
created this circular economy approach
so there's an orange and the orange pill
turns into into compost and the compost
grows the next tree that grows the next
oranges so that's that's the circular
economy approach in nature and we do the
same we Source we we work with
compostable raw materials we pack food
the package goes into the organic waste
stream turns into compost fertilizer and
then goes again into the system okay
okay so so a few a few quick questions
on that so 6 months is that by Design
from a commercial standpoint or is that
the you know why why the decision for 6
months is a threshold for for the
composable nature of the of the bag no
six months that's the regulation so the
regulation says that that the material
can be declared as composable as long as
it fully disintegrates so breaks down
into small parts and then those small
parts are consumed by bacteria eaten by
bacteria H only then you can claim that
uh we can CLA that the material is
compostible so so that's the regulation
it doesn't take 6 months it sometimes it
really takes much uh faster to for the
material to decompose but let's make
let's let me clear this point it's not
the shelf life so the shell it doesn't
happen on the Shelf so package can can
be on the shelf for a longer time much
longer time is as as much as
conventional plastic but once it goes
into the organic waste bin then the pro
there's a trigger for the proc process
to start and then the the material
breaks down into very very very small
parts those small parts are eaten by
bacteria the bacteria create the compost
and that's it vanished okay okay great
that that that's an an important
distinction and so tell me about the
founding of tipa so you're going for the
jog you're inspired by the conversation
with your kids you're looking for a
better solution how how does this now
lead to the forming of a comp
that does this in the physical world and
I'm looking through you know the success
stories of T and the different things
you're doing with your packaging I mean
this is just awesome um H how does how
does this whole company get started um
yeah good question so I have this I I
had this um ambition to do something by
myself um to invent to really make a
change in this world um and started to
work in this
path which I had no clue where I'm going
to um because as I said I'm a software
engineer not a plastic
engineer um but what I it seems to me
like the world needs that um
so um started working with the engineers
to develop to develop the material to
develop the solution at the same
time um raise
money um and if I do kind of fast for so
in the first few years we developed the
technology at around 2018 we started um
launching the technology in the market
to test it like um first first
generation the first generation was
emulating um poly poly ethylin
polyethylen is one of the materials that
conventional plastic uses so and and we
started that at 2018 we started working
in
Europe um and I can and and testing the
material on several types of products
like fresh produce bread snacks etc etc
uh working on the next Generations which
were then launched few few years
after and uh today we're active in
Australia in Europe and in North America
um we fully manfacture on theground in
North America in the last year we
started during 23 same with Australia so
the first the first Market was the
European one but then we extended to to
North America and Australia in the
recent year um and uh and yeah we have
success stories we have products in the
market many products in the market been
growing um and been and and mainly um um
through customers who believe in
compostables and through Partners who
believe in compostables how have you
experienced experienced the market over
the last several years obviously a big
movement a big awareness my father just
came back from cup 28 I know there's a
lot of conversation about what's
happening how how have how how has how
have you experienced the the trends in
the not in the you know big leaders
talking about climate change but in the
on the field on the ground the the
commercial people that need to spend the
money yeah by the way on on cop
28 um it's been several years now that
the plastic problem is not in the middle
of the discussion I mean it's kind of a
forgotten side which is not not a good
thing definitely um but uh if we're
talking about the public H the people
the
consumers um the people who make a
change in the world which is this is the
the consumers that's what eventually
they do the the evolution um the the
revolution
[Music]
um I can say that I I can say two things
first of all and consumers totally
understand what composable packaging in
is and are looking for composable
packages all surveys not by Tia but by
other companies show that there is a
huge demand for composable packaging
consumers are seeking for comp for for
companies who do not use conventional
plastic and definitely compossible
packaging is the solution for them on
the other hand there's um the
governments who
ignore um and and there's there's a huge
fight coming from companies who
manufacture conventional plastic uh
which are giants um so but definitely
the
spirit in the market is that there is a
need for compostible packaging we see a
huge shift in the nor North American
Market in the last two years I would say
towards compostables really very very
impressing H and and and giving
hope um we do
see
um new steps done in
Australia and and consumers and Brands
moving towards compostables Europe is
going back and forth for several reasons
although they were the first Market
to start with but there are few winds
blowing there that
um they Chang in in several cases the
spirit in the market but overall you
know what what we believe what I believe
as a person is is that the good things
win eventually and the truth wins
eventually so if this is a solution that
actually solves this problem eventually
it will be widely used as should be are
there
clear early adopters in the space that
you observe you know different types of
organizations or
verticals that are more likely to pursue
composable packaging rather than plastic
as early
adopters yeah yes so there's a there's a
the companies who are more do like
healthy food those are the ones who
looking to use the right Packaging
not use
plastic those are types of the early
adapters plus um plus eventually it's
kind of a you know the CEO Spirit or the
manager Spirit or the owner spirit so if
the owner is a True
Believer um then then we have a very
good partner to work with um and there
are companies who were exposed exposed
to to the option and and walked all this
uh way towards compostible so there's
different types of of early adapters but
it's mainly uh food food and fashion by
the way fashion as well we have a few uh
very impressing fashion companies who
use compost oil bags instead of
conventional plastic and in within the
food industry it's
the people who believe in it and people
who are in the space of uh healthy food
Etc in recently
in like in the last year we see the
bigger companies coming in like the
bigger players and this is very
encouraging like steps taken
by International Players which is very
promising as well if I if I have to ask
you to imagine two or three years down
the line on Tia's Journey you know your
vision where we're headed where where
where do you where do you see the world
Anda so I see I see the word uh adopting
more and more alternative Solutions one
of them is the composable solution
mainly in flexible packaging that's what
we do um and there's a reason for that
but I see mainly growth growth there I
see more and more as as we already see
today um alternative um alternative
materials playing a significant role in
different types of
packages um
[Music]
and I think there will be few Solutions
leaving one side to the other there's no
one solution that can actually
provide um can be an alternative to the
whole usage of of packaging and
definitely a see a significant growth
for tipa so we already have footprint in
three continents we'll continue to grow
there we'll have more Partners we work
by I mean we expand our um uh solutions
by Partnerships so so um so this is a
we'll see more and more partners coming
in and um and definitely a significant
growth incredible and if you have to
look at beyond that in the world Beyond
Tia from a consumer standpoint how do
you how do you expect consumers to shift
or consumer Behavior to shift over the
next few years do you think that this
will be more at the Forefront of
people's perception the same less
there's obviously a lot of things
happening around the world where is
plastic and sustainable packaging how is
that going to be compartmentalized do
you think in The Narrative of the
day-to-day conversations
so today it's already in the
conversations of The Narrative of
conversations for a with within
consumers um we definit we see more in
the younger generations and um but I
think it will expand to all generations
once we'll see more and more packages in
the market it will become kind of a
common practice or common usage or the
common solution for for packing food in
the right way um and I think that
consumers play a very important role
because what we see is consumers that
tend to
buy P products that are packed in the
right way uh and that actually will push
Brands to take steps into the right way
which
is uh reducing usage of plastic and uh
and as I said
earlier in my eyes and not only in my
eyes in
history revolutions
made by end consumers by the by the
public and in this case the public is
then
consumers love it defin thank you so
much best of luck with pea this was
great and inspiring appreciate the time
thank you so much for
everything and best of luck with
everything that you're doing best of
luck on this mission same to you thank
you very much thank you for the
opportunity thank you so much
[Music]